good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways to set and
achieve your goals rule no.5 is my
personal favorite and I share my take on
at the end of the video too and as
always as you're watching if anybody
says something that's really meaningful
to you that is makes you think and is
extra special extra special leaving the
comments below and put quotes around it
so that others can be inspired as well I
want to talk a little bit about goals on
the light of how do you lose 37 pounds
and write a book I'm just going to kind
of give you that as an example for 24
years of my adult life by choice I
weighed well over 200 pounds I say by
choice because you see I have never
accidentally eaten anything
I mean it's always been deliberate and
when I choose to eat too much today I
have chosen to weigh too much
tomorrow you can choose to set goals and
realize your potential or you can choose
not to set them now if you choose not to
set them you got to understand that the
consequences are not going to be good
down the road for 24 years I was going
to lose that way as a matter of fact in
24 years I lost several thousand pounds
of weight how many of you already know
exactly what I'm talking about but it
wasn't until I wrote it down put a date
on it listed the obstacles I had to
overcome identify the people the groups
organizations I needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action set that
time limit in there and identified all
of the benefits to me it was only when I
did that that the goal became a reality
and I lost the weight for 10 or 15 years
I was going to write a book you know
anybody who's going to do just a whole
lot of things folks I was going to write
a book but it wasn't until I got busy
writing the book and writing the plans
first before the book ever materialized
now if it sounds like I'm trying to sell
you on heaven goals how many of you are
getting close already how many of you
are becoming convinced right quick like
that you need to have those go there's
no question about it be immortal JC
Penney many many years ago said give me
a stock clerk with a goal and I'll give
you a man we'll make history but give me
a man without a goal and I'll give you a
stock clerk now the interesting thing is
goals do not care who has them let me
give you a classic example of the way
they work in 1950 a war-torn devastated
to Japan a nation who had lost an
incredibly high percentage of its young
men their cities were in ruins had been
bombed out but in 1950
they got together they meaning industry
and government got together and set a
goal the goal was we're going to be the
number one nation in the world during
the 1950s in the production of textiles
in 1959 ladies and gentlemen they
accomplished that objective in 1960 they
said another go we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of steel now when you
understand there's no iron ore in Japan
of any significance there's no coal of
any significance there we're gonna be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of steel it seemed like
an absurd goal and yet they reached
their objectives they had taken all of
the steps in 1970 the Japanese said
another goal they said during the
seventies we would be the number one
nation in the world in the production of
automobiles they missed it folks
one year it took them until 1980 in 1980
they said another gold and this time
their goal was we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of computers and electronics
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must have those goes
the goal has to be specific and
measurable how much by win when there
isn't any criteria for measurement it is
simply something you want we call it a
wish a preference or just a good idea
but it doesn't register in the mind as a
goal so you got to decide what is it you
want and then be specific for example I
want to lose weight is vague but it
might become I will weigh a hundred and
thirty-five pounds by August 1st at 5
p.m. or I will increase my income to
$80,000 a year by December 31st at
midnight or I will live in a 35,000
square foot home as big as the one built
Gateshead by December 31st at midnight
now notice in these examples they all
stated how much by when a specific
amount that you can measure by a
specific time that can be measured now
an easy place to start when you're
setting goals is to simply look at one
area in your life that you would like to
be different it might be where there's
something negative or disturbing that
you'd like to eliminate or it might be
where something missing that you'd like
to create something you'd like more of
more money more love more time now once
you've decided what you want you can
either do something about it or not it's
your choice and you have the
responsibility for your choices but bear
in mind that you have to be willing to
change your behavior and do something
different if you want to create a
different outcome you have to be willing
to take whatever risks are necessary to
get what you want now if you've already
taken some initial steps in the right
direction towards some of your goals
now's the time to decide what next steps
do you need to take to keep moving you
toward your chosen goal you see it's
very liberating when you finally realize
that you have the power to make your
life whatever you want it to be it's a
wonderful feeling knowing that your
success does not really depend on anyone
else so if you're looking for one thing
to do different today than you did
yesterday make it this commit to taking
100% responsibility for every aspect of
your life then choose what it is you
want decide what actions you're going to
need to take to create it and then take
those actions one
step at a time now there are a lot of
things you can learn to do to accelerate
your success but the basics that will
move you from where you are to where you
want to be are simply this decide what
you want take control of your thoughts
visualize what you want make a plan and
then take action actualize your plan
start with these simple steps that I
promise you that you'll start seeing the
results you want in order to be
successful you must have one big goal I
give a goal setting exercise all over
the world that is life-changing I go
back a year later or two years later or
three years later and I have thousands
of people come up to me almost like us
guru or a sage and they say you changed
my life you made me rich and I said it
was the goals wasn't it and they said
yes it was the goals how did you know
and what I teach is this is take a piece
of paper make a list of 10 goals that
you'd like to achieve in the next 12
months
these are one-year goals now sometimes
I'll have a one day a one week one month
three months six months but they're all
goals that you want to accomplish within
12 months then you look over this list
and you say if I could wave a magic wand
and achieve any one goal on this list
within 24 hours which one goal would
have the greatest positive impact on my
life and then you look at your list of
ten and the answer will jump out at you
and that becomes your major definite
purpose this becomes your major goal
then you transfer this to a clean sheet
of paper and you write a deadline when
you want to achieve this goal you make a
list of everything that you can think of
that you could do to achieve this goal
you then organize this list like a
checklist in order of sequence what do
you do first what do you do second what
do you do third and then you take action
on your goal and then you do something
on that goal every day seven days a week
it's a very simple system decide the
most important goal write it down make a
plan work on it every day and then all
of your other goals will start to move
forward you'll start to make progress on
the big goal but all the other goals
will start to move forward almost
without you even paying attention to
them so that's really the key to success
is single focus
Warren Buffett and Bill Gates were at a
dinner party with Bill Gates father and
a large number of other people at Bill
Gates home in Seattle last year and they
were chatting with each other they're
very good friends and somebody came up
to them and said excuse me gentlemen
don't mean to interrupt you but you're
three of the most important most
successful people in the world Bill
Gates and Warren Buffett are number one
number two wealthiest men in the world
what would you say is the most important
ingredient for success and they all
stopped broke off their conversation and
all turned simultaneously and looked at
the man and said focus focus is the most
important quality for success if you can
focus you can do anything has there been
anything in your life that you've ever
wanted so badly you were so desirous of
it yet such a hunger for it that you
couldn't stop thinking about it could
been a career move could have been when
you're a kid a car it could have been a
relationship it could have been anything
but you were obsessed you wanted to make
this happen you wanted to track this to
your life you wanna you just wanted
something and you didn't even know how
to get it but it was so compelling to
you kept thinking about it every day and
visioning and imagining it feeling it
and then stuff happened and suddenly you
started attract people or situations to
your life and it just came together like
you didn't even have a total plan it was
just that it was so a part of your focus
with so much intensity and emotion so
often that it sensitized you to notice
anything that could get you there
there's a part of your brain called the
reticular activating system for short we
call it the RAS that part of your brain
determines what you notice in the world
and it's really important because when
you set a goal when you get really clear
on a vision they're strong enough
reasons and you review it enough it
becomes a part of you that part of your
brain says anything that relates to this
I need to notice so I did you ever buy a
certain kind of car or maybe a certain
outfit and suddenly you see that car
everywhere are those outfits everywhere
you know the cars were always around but
why do you see it now because your Ras
knows this is important this is part of
my world now similarly when you really
get clear and it's compelling and you're
reviewing it every day got strong
reasons you're viewing it every day in
your
killing it the brain becomes incredibly
acute at noticing anything to get you to
move forward and so that's the power of
this so you know what do people do with
New Year's resolution they come up with
something they kind of want it's not a
compelling vision they don't really have
strong enough reasons and they never
review it again until to notice that
they broke what they said they really
want to have make happen because they
didn't really resolve if you resolve you
got the vision it's compelling you
review it daily and you feel it you
envision it and you experience it simple
as it sounds all ideas don't work unless
you do the work and some of the best
work you can do is getting really good
at creating a one-page plan have your
big five the five things that need to
happen this year for this to be your
best year yet on a one-page plan your
top five values put them on that same
plan your top five sub goals sequenced
into each quarter of this year on that
one page plan and every morning all your
competition or the rest of the world is
asleep get up at 5:00 a.m. I'll teach
you how to do that in future videos but
look at your one page plan spend 20
minutes on that so it becomes a brain
tattoo a burning obsession so it all
lights you with inspiration so you go
out in the world and you understand that
clarity is power and you so intimately
know what has to happen during this day
this week this month this quarter this
year to get you closer to your mountain
top because the ordinary though the
hours that ordinary people waste
extraordinary people do because they're
not bored like most people most people
need to medicate themselves with too
much TV
too much Facebook too much video too
much chitchat too much busyness because
they don't know their goals because they
don't have a one-page plan because they
don't have a one-page schedule I mean
I've got my schedule for every seven
days almost everything I need to do goes
on it and you might say Robin well
that's a very rigid way to live no it's
a very free way to live because then I
have the power to live life on my own
terms I feel inspired I'm not wasting
each day I'm leveraging each day and I
want you really right now once again
start thinking about your goals and
about your dreams and as you begin to
envision them one of the things that I
think that's very important
we have to always go back to as you look
at your goals and dreams and and I want
you to expand them and it's very
important to realize that I found that
most people fail in life not because
they aim too high and miss most people
fail in life because they did just like
I did for so many years they aim too low
and hit they didn't believe in
themselves so I want you right now as we
begin to think about the lessons and all
the things that you've experienced and
all of the comments and stories and
strategies and lessons that you've had I
think it's time to revisit and look at
your goals and dreams and let's raise
the bar I remember as a kid we would be
in the backyard and we would play
jumping somebody would get on one side
of the stick my sister and then my
brother
we were running we're jump over it and
then they'd say raise it a little bit
higher we have to back up rewrite a whip
jump over together and then we say raise
it up a little high and the higher it
got we have to begin to change our
approach and how are we going to get
over the bar and that's the same thing
in life and so right now I want you to
think about your goals and dreams as you
begin to raise them a little higher and
I want you to stay with me it's possible
it's possible you know the easiest thing
that I do is speak and trade people how
to speak go into prisons and juvenile
detention centers and to high schools
and colleges speak before thousands of
people I can do that in my sleep let me
share with you the the most difficult
thing I've ever done in my life it took
me years to do and that was to believe
that it was possible to believe that I
can do it given my circumstances born
and abandoned building on a floor being
adopted being labeled educable mentally
[ __ ] failing twice and school no
college training never worked for a
major corporation to believe that I had
something of value to say that somebody
would want to listen to me to believe
that that somebody would pay me to talk
to them have you ever thought about
something you wanted to do and you
talked yourself out of it I remember
going to see Zig Ziglar who
I consider the number one motivational
speaker in the planet and dr. norman
vincent peale when he was alive in
robert schuller
i see them and i would be so pumped up
and inspired after here Jim Ron who
recently passed one of the great
motivational speakers of all time and
and Charlie tremendous Jones it and I
would go to my car pumped up say yes yes
yes I can and then after a while my
mental conditioning would kick in and I
say Les Brown you can't do that you
don't have a college education that's
brown you can't do that you know your
parents are that's from you can't do
that you feel twice in school come on
ever thought about something you wanted
to do and you talked yourself out of it
there's a proverb that says if there's
no enemy within the enemy outside can do
us no harm that's why it's important
that you make it a point every day to
listen to Paul to listen to me to review
these lessons to to get them deep not
only in the conscious mind but the
subconscious mind and get them in your
spirit well how often should I do it do
it until you are producing the results
that's how often you should do it and
and you never stop because once you stop
that's when those negative thoughts will
come back once you stop that's when you
will begin to doubt yourself once you
stop I'm telling you what I know
yes every day it's a selling job on you
it's possible I can do this I can make
this happen no matter how bad it is or
how bad it gets I'm going to make it
it's possible yes your dream is possible
say that to yourself every day feed your
mind with words that you write in words
that you hear and words that you speak
to yourself feed your faith and your
doubts will starve to death
say to yourself it's possible it's
possible it's possible even when you
have no evidence to point to say to
yourself
it's possible there's nothing as
powerful as a maid of mine it's a
struggle some time to do that especially
when you have people around you telling
you that it's not possible that you
can't do it and they're constantly
pointing out your failures of the past
constantly reminding you of all of the
things that you don't have going for you
I'm reminded of a story of two little
boys that were playing on Timaeus during
the winter and and and as they got
further out on this ice one filled
through the the thin ice and and so the
little fellow that was still on top of
the ice he was trying to save his little
buddy and he couldn't reach him he was
trying to pull him he could see him
through the thin ice as he got further
away from him struggling and and he
couldn't reach him and he's trying to
break the ice and he couldn't do it he
looked around and he saw a tree in the
distance and he ran and then he got up
on the tree and he pulled and broke down
an enormous size branch and came back
and and savagely begin to beat that ice
and broke it and and miraculously he
saved his friend and when the paramedics
came and they were able to revive this
little boy they were scratching their
heads they're trying to figure this out
said how could this little pruning
fellow go up in a tree and break off a
branch this size and then come back and
beat and break the ice and save his
friend they thought it was just
miraculous baffling and an old guy who
was there said I can tell you how he did
it and they said how how did he do it
and he said there was no one here to
tell him that he couldn't do it whoa
what could you do what could I do what
could all of us do if we did not have
the naysayers in our lives that that we
believed naively like that little boy
that it was possible what would you do
if a Lea was not on the table do you
realize that 87% of people allow the
fear
fear of failure to outlive their desire
to succeed because they've been
convinced by the evidence by being
practical by being illogical by being
realistic I did that Leslie yes you're
going to speak for corporations yes
Leslie do they have a college education
yes
do you Wesley you know that I don't have
a college education
Leslie are these people experienced yes
are there people with PhDs and MBAs that
they could choose rather than choose you
yes so you don't have a college
education you have no experience you're
talking about becoming a speaker and
they're going to reach over people with
PhDs and MBAs and years of experience
and choose you are you being realistic
come on Leslie come on Leslie you can't
do this my brother if he is he's a
wonderful person and and and he
constantly reminded me that I I couldn't
do what I'm doing now and but that
really wasn't a bad part the real bad
part was I convinced myself that I
couldn't do it not only because of those
things that he pointed out being
practical and realistic but also that
within myself I didn't believe what Mike
Williams my mentor said was possible for
me have you ever had somebody who
believed and saw something for you that
you didn't see for yourself and here's
how I escaped that I discovered that
sometimes you have to believe in
somebody's belief in you until your
belief kicks in so for me goal-setting
the most important thing is making sure
that I have a strong Y attached to it
that it's something deep and meaningful
and important for me to accomplish I
remember I would you know listen to a
motivational tape or watch a video and
get all I'm top and you know the guy on
that tape or CD and old school would be
talking about something like making
cards or making a sculpture or doing all
these things like man that's great I
want to I want to make art I want to
make a sculpture too and then I
you know I don't actually really want to
make a sculpture it was just I was kind
of fired up in that moment and I think a
lot of people set the wrong goals for
themselves it has to be something that
you feel on a deep emotional level
connected to because there's me a lot of
work that you have to go through to go
and accomplish that goal and so if you
don't have the strong why you're not
going to follow through the next thing
for me is is setting yourself up for
success and blocking off chunks of time
in your calendar so that you can achieve
that goal it's great to have a goal but
you need to be able to follow through on
it and the way to do it is you create
your calendar and you put all your
personal stuff in there as well as your
business stuff in there and then you
make the time for everything you have a
goal for so if you want to send more
time with your spouse or your boyfriend
or your girlfriend then you make sure
that's in the calendar and you're
blocking off Tuesday and Thursday
evening to spend time with them if you
want to make sure you're spending time
on your YouTube channel or on your sales
and marketing you're on your product
development pick a day in the calendar
and that's the day that you're focused
on your YouTube channel or your product
development or your sales and marketing
you have to make it important and block
up chunks of time and not get distracted
because otherwise it's just a good
intention but you don't follow through
until you create the time for and the
third thing I would say is make sure
that you adjust your goals as you adjust
and evolve as human being things that I
wanted to do my goals are not the same
that they were five years ago that they
were one year that year ago that maybe
they were three months ago as I change
and evolve my goals have to in change
and evolve with me and if you feel
yourself frustrated with what's
happening right now we feel yourself
drawn to something that you want to go
and try make sure that you're adjusting
your goals and your lifestyle and your
mindset to people accommodate changes in
the evolution of yourself
so that's my quick take thank you guys
so much for watching I made this video
because our John Sahni asked me to so
there's a topic that you would like me
to cover in the next edition of believe
life leaving the comments below and I'll
see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the clips
meant the most to you how is it going to
impact you what changes you're going to
make to your goal-setting and you're
following through now as a result of
watching this video maybe make a goal
make it public by leaving it in the
comments below I'm really curious to
hear your feedback and finally I want to
give a quick shout out to Christina our
video editor Christina Christina bought
a copy of my book I really appreciate
that Christina you want to say something
hey the book little bit awesome I know
it so thanks again Christina really
appreciate it for those of you guys
watching if you want to change at a
shadow in the future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book it's really
good I promise an email in your receipts
that we can keep track thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
clarify what you want so I don't think
in terms of goals as much as I think in
terms of what I want
so the first step I'm going to do is
this I'm going to come in on day one and
I'm going to do this over a series of
days with my wife and then with my
company with the executives and with
everybody involved in the company and
I'm going to clarify what it is I want
for instance I write down here 2013 and
I sit down with a pen and a piece of
paper I do not do this with a computer
this is a personal little thing for me
to write it down with E because I get to
free flow and create on it okay
and so on day one I'm going to just
start writing down okay without any
mechanics without any understanding of
how to do it how to get it this is
merely what I want to happen I am NOT
concerned with action at this point I'm
not concerned with mechanics or how to
do it I'm concerned with hey what do I
want what is the perfect situation if I
could make it happen this year I was
sitting at a roundtable with executives
one day and a person that is highly
successful I could tell was a little
discouraged he said John I've hit every
goal in my life and now I basically have
lost my motivation and my passion and I
looked at him I called him by name I'll
say Don it wasn't his name so done the
problem is you've been goal oriented
instead of growth oriented you see if
you and I are just goal oriented when we
hit our goals that's kind of like Eureka
we've arrived we celebrate have a party
but that all of a sudden there's an
emptiness like okay I've hit it but if
your growth oriented and establish goals
within your growth oriented journey
you'll hit those goals but you'll look
at it say hey this is just another step
towards my total growth and I've never
known a person who said John I've grown
as big as I can ever
oh and I know as much as I can ever know
and so therefore I have nothing to
accomplish you see if you're
goal-oriented you'll hit your goal and
then be a little empty but if you're
growth-oriented
you'll never hit that goal just keep
growing I was raised in a little town of
yesu City Mississippi now I know a lot
of folks go around the country trying to
impress people by claiming to be from
Yazoo City but I really am now when I
was a boy during the Depression we live
next door to some rich folks I knew they
were rich for two reasons everyone had a
cook number two the cook had something
to cook during the Depression that was a
sure sign of wealth I was over there for
lunch one day as I tried to be every day
and don't misunderstand that even though
there was a depression on we certainly
had plenty to eat at my house I know we
had plenty because if I ever passed my
place for seconds that always tell me
know you've had plenty so I know we had
plenty now they could brought the
biscuits out in this is not an
exaggeration those biscuits were not as
thick as my wrist was and I looked at
him for a moment I said Maude what in
the world happened to you biscuits she
read back gave a big old-timer life and
said well I'll tell you about those
biscuits she said they squatted to rise
but she said they just got cooked in the
squat
you know anybody's getting cooked in the
squad
you know dividing who's going to do
something just as soon as are there half
of mine to do such-and-such thing ever
have anybody say well you know wait the
kids get out of school and then I'll
really get involved in this project we
got so many things going on right now
Whateley out of school lately summertime
comes in an hour
you're busy the kids get out of school
you know what to say then well you know
I didn't realize but I got to take the
kids somewhere every day I had more time
with their risk away to get back in
school and then I little get busy kids
get back until you know what they say
then well you know for the first time in
19 years dear old centralized finally
got a winning football team and you got
to support their kids we left to the
football signals over then I'll really
get busy football scene then you know
what they say then well here it is
Thanksgiving and Christmas and New
Year's and people don't want to be
bothered with this sort of thing this
time here wait lap to the first of the
year man that I really get busy after
the first year you know what they say
well it's the wealthy
did you ever see weather like this in
Chicago or San Francisco or Dallas or
wherever Whateley weather settles down
and then I'll really get busy oh I know
what you're thinking you're thinking
I've lost 8% but that's not the way I do
they did a different edition let me take
the way I do think now here's the way I
am sir well this is why I do it
see the way I do things is I get
everything organized I get it lined up I
have everything in just such and such
order and then man once I get it all put
together that's when I really get after
I mean that's just the way I've always
been that way do things that way I know
some of these other folks were hit on me
right now but you just wait I'll catch
them but this weather it is just so
horrible wait Lee clears up and the
weather clears up you know what to say
then well here it is it's Easter time
and the Easter time you know that's the
family time and we always spend a lot of
time together and you said so yourself
the family is extremely important to you
you do the work for the family and we
can't spend some time with them you
might as well I do all the work I mean
wait laughs tracers over then I'll
really get busy and then after you know
what they say at long last we've got
some beautiful weather and I haven't hit
a golf ball of weather hooking I don't
know when man I gotta have some R&R
I gotta have some rest and relaxation
and you know you said you can't work all
the time I mean an individual needs some
type of them said wait live relax a
little bit of man that I really get
after it and finally they get after a
little bit you know or when they have
the fun and relaxation then they say
well it's almost time for the kids to
get out of school that's where we came
in
as we say down-home folks you can put
this in your pipe and smoke it cause
it's the truth
the people who wait for aunt Matilda to
move out or Johnny get on the day shift
are the new models to come out are the
new mayor to come in are for the new
advertising campaign to get started the
people who wait on the new senator in
Washington are until inflation slows or
the rate of interest come down but
people who wait for changes to take
place out there before they do the
changing in here our flat going to end
up getting cooked in the squat the rule
is simple you do it now you do it now